مجتمعنا موحد
ونعلم جميعًا في بلدنا أن هذه
ليست قتالًا بين مسيحيين ومسلمين
أو نمساويين
وأشخاص من دول أخرى ، إنها
معركة
يجب أن نقاتلها معًا ، إنها حرب
ضد
الإرهاب وهي حرب ضد
من الواضح تمامًا أن هذا
الهجوم الإرهابي كان
هجومًا إرهابيًا إسلاميًا ،
حيث وُلد المسلح في النمسا ولديه خلفية مهاجرة
من شمال
مقدونيا وما نعرفه أيضًا
هو أنه مؤيد للدولة الإسلامية
لأن
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون هو  خرج
بعد وقوع الهجوم هنا وقال إن
هذه أمة صديقة في أوروبا
تعرضت للهجوم من قبل أه النمسا
هل تصدق أن أه الوضع
في فرنسا
الجدل الجديد حول شارلي
عبدو الأحداث في لطيفة على سبيل المثال
التي ربما لعبت دور  الدور الذي
نحاول معرفة ما إذا كانت هناك روابط بين
هذا الهجوم الإرهابي في
النمسا وتلك التي حدثت في فرنسا
ولكن من
الناحية الإيديولوجية  إنه دائمًا ما يكون هو
نفسه ، إنه الإسلام السياسي ،
إنه فكرة جعل الشباب راديكاليين
من أجل تطرف الجيل الثاني
من الناس الذين يعيشون في مجتمعاتنا لمحاربة
مجتمعاتنا وهذا هو التحدي الرئيسي
الذي
سنواجهه في الاتحاد الأوروبي كيف نتعامل
معه  هؤلاء الناس
أه وأه كيف يقاتلون ليس فقط
الإرهابيين أنفسهم
ولكن أيضًا أولئك
الذين يحاولون تضليل الشباب
في المساجد
ومحاولة نشر هذه الأفكار في مجتمعاتنا
ما هي رسالة النمسا
إلى العالم بعد هذا الهجوم ولكن أيضًا إلى
الأشخاص الذين يريدون تقسيم
المجتمع بالطبع سنبقى ملتزمين في
معركتنا ضد هؤلاء الإرهابيين
، سنبقى ملتزمين في معركتنا
ضد الأيديولوجية الكامنة وراءنا
ولكننا لن نسمح بحدوث أن
مجتمعنا منقسم لأننا يجب أن
نتحد
في هذه المعركة.